[موسيقى]
ليس الابناء فقط وحتى البنات البنات
هم يقيمون في الخارج
واولادهم يدرسون بناتهم وبنينهم ونحن
نشجعهم نحن لا نستذكر هذا الامر
وانا اذكر حتى هناك كانت لقاء من سي ان ان
ما اهم احد مسؤولين طالبان وهو المتحدث
الرسمي للسيد شاهين قال انت بنتك تدرس في
قطر وفي جامعه قال نعم هي محجبه وهل
للمراه الافغانيه سيد مشاري انت تعرف جيدا
وهل هناك امراه ثانيه غير محجبه سواء كانت
جمهوريه او غير جمهوريه هل هناك المراه
افغانيه تصرع الى الفواحش
[موسيقى]
واذكركم بنقطه اخرى ان لم اتاخر
من اسباب منع تعليم المراه من الجامعات
الموضوع المحرم
في مساكن طالبات وموضوع
المنهج الدراسي لم يكن اسلامي فانا اسال
السؤال
المنهج غير اسلامي للبنين والبنات فما
معنى انك تمنع البنت وتترك الولد